What do you think of the gallery test?
So I'm very familiar with the gallery test.
I've had the rep contact the multiple times.
I met with the rep one time.
The gallery test doesn't interest me at all.
Unless the person does not know if they have cancer,
and they want a good cancer screening test
to find out if they have a high probability of cancer.
The gallery test does not, you cannot tell a person.
The other results of the gallery test
that they definitively have cancer,
but you can tell a person that there's a really good chance
that you have cancer, you need to go
and get further investigation.
So for a person that has already been diagnosed with cancer,
already knows they have cancer.
Already has been through treatment of cancer.
To me, the gallery test is an absolutely zero value.
So really the gallery test shines with people who,
hey, I don't want to go to a doctor
to find out I have cancer.
I have this mess in my breast or whatever.
I don't feel good.
I don't, I don't, I just feel like it.
I got there something wrong.
And you want a screening test,
well, then the gallery test can be a good example.
There's other tests like this as well.
The using the same technology is the colo guard test,
but that one, you have to go to a medical doctor
and get it prescribed.
But that one only tests for colo rectal cancer.
It uses the same technology
as the IVG test for those of you who remember back four years ago
when the IVG test was available.
It uses DNA recombinant technology.
So it's a valuable test,
but if it does not give you a score
and like the IVG test gave you,
that's what made the IVG test so unique.
The gallery test does not do that.
So as far as grading your cancer,
as far as knowing if you're getting better or worse,
et cetera, there's, to me, there's,
for some of the originals they have cancer, it's zero value.
So, but I explain that to the rap,
because we never went any further
because it's just to make any sense at all to different patients.
I have the opportunity to get folded in a therapy locally,
funds allowing how often and how many sessions
is reasonable for me to, for my current condition.
Both are expensive.
I was going to do the gallery
because of my unexplained elevated AFP.
I would not say that the gallery
is going to give you information that you want from that.
But then thought,
why not do the photodynamic therapy instead at least once?
So, understand photodynamic therapy
that is offered,
I would investigate what tools
that they're using,
what equipment that they're using.
If it is true photodynamic therapy,
then I would say, if you have the option
to do one or the other, I would do that.
Just, you know, we've talked about this,
I think this question about photodynamic therapy came up
oh, about six, eight months ago,
there's no patented on that term.
So, photodynamic therapy means light therapy.
So, there are laser companies that are selling laser,
lasers as photodynamic therapy.
I know that true photodynamic therapy does use lasers.
That's why it's called photodynamic therapy,
but it uses a drug, a chemical,
and it's very specific to the cancer and it's pinpointed.
It's more elaborate technology than just a, you know,
level one, two, three, or four laser.
So, you, I would investigate that.
But for sure, I would choose a therapy over the test.